mais d'abord on prend donc la direction
de Saint-Antoine du rocher la petite
commune du nord Touraine secouée depuis
l'arrestation la semaine dernière de son
maître d'école pour détention d'images
pédopornographique 56
000 fichiers au total retrouvés dans son
ordinateur en attendant la mise en place
d'une cellule d'écoute à la rentrée
certains parents se sentent démunis face
aux angoisses de leurs enfants sur place
Hélène chapelet
comment expliquer à ses élèves se
conduire proche comment trouver les bons
mots alors que les vacances débutent
c'est aux parents d'élèves de faire ce
difficile travail le professeur a été
arrêté mardi soir ici même juste après
la classe et même s'il a été remplacé
dès jeudi dernier les services de
l'éducation nationale n'ont pas eu le
temps de mettre en place une cellule
d'écoute psychologique un papa
rencontrait tout à l'heure me confier
que sa fille avait le mise en cause
depuis deux ans comme maître et qu'elle
avait été très perturbée par cette
histoire qu'elle avait fait des
cauchemars et qu'elle avait demandé à sa
maman de dormir avec elle un papa qui a
également insisté sur le fait que le
maître était très apprécié le 49
exerçait ici depuis six ans et personne
n'avait jamais rien eu à lui reprocher
au niveau de son comportement avec ses
élèves
les parents ils voilà ils sont un peu
surpris parce que au sein de l'école
tout se passait bien c'était un prof qui
était apparemment super je pense que ça
va se estomper un petit peu mais c'est
vrai que les premiers enfants ça les
aperte un petit peu de savoir que leur
maître était voilà
emmené par les gendarmes
se mettre d'école enseignait depuis 2006
il a exercé pendant 12 ans sur des
postes fractionnés en Indre-et-Loire
elle la direction académique ne fait
état d'aucune plainte à son encontre il
est aujourd'hui suspendu de ses
fonctions et n'a plus le droit d'entrer
en contact avec ses élèves dès la
rentrée des classes un espace d'écoute
sera mise en place à l'école pour
répondre aux questions des enfants ce
sont des professionnels d'éducation
nationale ça peut être effectivement des
infirmières des psychologues assistantes
sociales qui viennent et qui s'installe
à disposition de l'école toute la
journée pour recevoir en tout cas les
interrogations conseiller etc donc cette
cellule sera mise en place toute la
journée dès la rentrée
l'enseignant qui vit à tour a été mise
en examen pour détention d'images
pédopornographiques il est placé sous
contrôle judiciaire